are there techniques for anti-aging that
aren't surgical that you could recommend
like does botox botox work do fillers
work are there lasers that can resurface
skin like does anything else work are
there creams
yeah there's lots of stuff for sure
good skin care is always wonderful and
important but from a skin care
perspective the most important thing
from my perspective and i don't
prescribe skincare and i have good
dermatology colleagues and work in
cosmetic dermatology that i refer to
but the primary thing that i think
that's important is you should be on is
some kind of a retin-a or a vitamin a
derivative and those are skin creams
um retinol is like an example of it but
retinol is not that strong but
prescriptive retin-a
thickens the collagen laser your skin
and prevents aging it actually supports
thickness of the skin and the pro layers
that tend to thin out as we get older so
that's a really important thing to do
and it's something that people should do
throughout their life because it
definitely will help minimize how much
the skin falls and wrinkles so that's
one thing botox is wonderful because
when you put botox in if you're not
flexing your face all the time you don't
develop lines and wrinkles in the
forehead around the eyes it helps
support the brows so it prevents aging
so botox even though it can be costly
over a very long period of your life
because if you started younger say in
your mid to late 30s and you continued
on with it for a long time it gets
expensive
but is it worth yes it is
fillers you have to be very careful with
and i talk about this a lot lecture all
over the world about it the problem with
fillers is they create something called
the tissue expansion effect
and what that means is as you put filler
in you stretch the tissues out
when you stretch the tissues out it's
like a pregnant woman when they have a
pregnant belly they lose the pregnant
belly there's a lot of skin that gets it
develops and it hangs
so a lot of women get tummy tucks
because the skin has been so stretched
out after pregnancy
similarly with fillers if you overdo
fillers you will stretch your face out
and if you do that it'll actually make
it drop more quickly
so one of the big problems that i deal
with in my practice is women who started
phyllis too young
because they thought they were
preventing their aging but they stretch
their face out so they need a facelift
much younger
than they probably would have sometimes
by even a decade
so fillers are good
when done with small quantities with a
with an even hand
but when you start blowing things up too
much unfortunately this could be a
significant problem
wow that's something people should
really know about because they're you go
on instagram and it's like oh do the you
know kylie jenner package or something
and it's yeah well yeah it's easy to
market and it's simple it's not surgery
it's just a couple of injections and
sometimes it can look really good
but the problem is is how frequently you
do it and how much you do at one time
because it can look good the first time
in the second time but sometimes after
people doing it the fourth 56th time as
they continue to age
they're putting more and more stuff in
to try to recreate the same effect but
our aging face doesn't recreate the same
effect with the injections that it did
say five years ago or seven years ago so
people try to use more to get what they
used to get but then all they do is they
stretch their face out
okay and you mentioned something about
fat grafting
so
what's the difference between that and
just having a face
so fat grafting is just like using
filler it's just using your own body fat
so the thing is is that
any place where you can use filler you
can do something more permanent with fat
similarly
fat can cause the same problems that
fillers can so it has to be done evenly
and not too much
but the other problem is is that if you
put a lot of fat in the face
it can weigh the face down because it
has more weight than filler does
so similarly with time and age fat
grafting tends to drag the face down
because it's like strapping two weights
into the face
so all these things are a matter of
degree
but it's more common for me not to do
fat grafting in younger patients and
here's the reason why
fat is a hormonally active tissue
so when women go through changes and
start to have hormonal changes as they
age
a lot of women start to gain a little
bit of weight and it's not
because they're not trying hard but it's
a lot easier to stay thin when you're 20
than when you are when you're in your
mid to late 40s right for everybody
the problem is that the fat that you put
in the face acts like the fat from your
belly
so if you start to put weight on in your
body because your metabolism is changed
guess what happens to the fat in your
face
it grows
so what i see is i see a lot of women
who are fat crafting in their 30s whose
faces now are getting big and distortive
and they weren't like that when they
were younger because the fat
was one size but as they put weight on
the fat in the face grows like as if it
was in the belly because it grow it
behaves like where it came from
not where it was placed
so the face gets very distorted so for
me fat grafting i prefer to use it in
patients who are older who have already
been through some of those metabolic
changes versus trying to use it as a
substitute for fillers fellows can be
dissolved away
fat cannot so when you have a problem
with fat correcting it becomes a big
surgical problem
that a lot of people would prefer to
avoid and you learn these this is the
thing
when you do so much of this and i've
done so many thousands of surgeries i've
made a lot of mistakes and i've learned
from those mistakes over the years
that's what happens that's what good
surgeons do
so as a result
i know how to avoid more of those
problems for my patients and i know who
the right patients are to direct to what
treatments in what amounts at what time
in their life
that's wild that you can graft belly fat
or something like that and then it'll
gain weight like belly fat that's crazy
i bet people didn't expect that that's
where it came from it doesn't confuse
its character
we're using it to like resupplement but
it has the character of where it came
from
wow
okay
that's very cool okay so
now that we have a bit of a background
about all this
actually no one question first so you
said facelifts used to be
a lot scarier than they are and you used
to end up with just like scars
everywhere
yeah very visible scars and very long
incision lines so you it would be very
very hard to camouflage against the
surgery you know you'd have to kind of
wear your hair down and hide everything
as much as you could and if you ever had
to go get your hair cut or jump in the
pool everybody would see these horrible
scars
everywhere which is not fun nobody wants
i mean even if you look good you don't
want to have
a visible telltale sign anywhere you
don't you want your face to look normal
but you also don't want to have
you know visible scars that tell
everybody where you've been and what
you've done
so what's the difference between that
and now like how come there are so many
older celebrities that are in their 60s
that look absolutely fantastic and they
don't look like they have any scars or
people can't tell otherwise they'd be
you know all over the magazines because
they've had good surgery you know
you know arguable there are lots of
great surgeons out there
when somebody's at like an award show
and everybody's like holy crap what
happened to that person
knows they had you know not a great
procedure and they probably had a
technique and a you know an approach
that was you know used decades ago but
that still happens a lot
you know there's a good and high
percentage of patients who go to doctors
who have those techniques and then there
are more evolved techniques
and unfortunately probably a smaller
percentage of surgeons are educated and
capable with those techniques
but those are the people that you see
who are 60 years old and a celebrity and
you're like she looks great like you
don't say oh my god she looks ex-age you
just like look at her and you can't even
perceive her age because she just looks
fantastic
that's the beautiful classic
i've always wondered if
there was any correlation between
looking younger and
and age length age span i don't know if
or lifespan i don't know if they've done
any studies on that but i've talked to
people who've had procedures done who've
lo who look now 15 years younger and
they say they feel younger too
yeah i definitely think that there's
health benefits
but i think it's because
when people look better
and they're more prideful of their
appearance
they tend to lead healthier lifestyles
so people who have a better more
youthful looking face will often
exercise more they'll eat more you know
more carefully
because they want this to match this
so i think that it sets in motion habits
that make people live a longer and
potentially healthier life for sure
so that's where i think the link is i
don't think it's generated in the brain
i think it's generated by habit that's
just reinforces better habits and i've
seen it over and over again i do a
procedure on a patient and then i see
them six months later they've lost 25
pounds they look fantastic
because they're like well this looks
great like before
you know my body wasn't my concern
because my face really didn't look great
now this looks fantastic and now my body
becomes my concern
you know because i want it all to look
great together
so that's where i think that comes in
i